trois attaques peut-être cette nous
dit-on de source policière en tout cas
au moins trois ont été perpétrés à paris
et autour de paris
on n'a jamais connu un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de paris on n'a jamais été
confronté à une action ans de guerre
[Musique]
c'est la guerre avec l'odeur de la
poudre du sang la vision c'est la guerre
on pense pas trop hein ce qu'on l'a on
essaie surtout de prendre les bonnes
décisions
déterminées qui a fait quoi
très bon
avec qui et pourquoi
c'est une toile le kwassa père et c'est
tellement énorme je pars de trois
personnes qui nous ont tiré dessus un an
après on me parle d'une quantité de gens
on me parle du financement des armes de
tout devient énorme
45000 code 45 mille pièces de procédure
mille sept cent quarante parties civiles
et 350 avocat ce jour pour moins six
mois d'audiences dans une salle de 600
places spécialement construite au coeur
du palais de justice de paris
c'est un procès de très grande ampleur
et qui donc dû comparable à rien ce
procès on n'a pas le choix il doit être
historique
que n'at-on pas fait que n'at-on pas
empêché comment ces attentats ont ils pu
se produire
c'est la liberté qui aura le dernier mot
vous avez agi de manière effroyable vous
allez être condamné de manière
démocratique
[Musique]
c'est un procès d'assises
c'est un processus solennel
c'est un procès essentiel pour
l'histoire notre pays
on n'a jamais eu de procès avec 1700
partie civile
on n'a jamais eu non plus de procès qui
allait durer autant de temps avec autant
de victimes et avec une tombe difficulté
on n'a jamais cru ça je mets
le temps de l'attentât est très court
le temps de la victime est très long et
le temps le plus long c'est le temps
judiciaire
mais c'est important pour les victimes
de se repositionner dans ce temps-là
oups
[Musique]
et ce qui est pas évident à ce moment là
c'est de savoir finalement mois victime
quelle est ma place là dedans
[Musique]
on a eu une discussion à peu continue
sur tout un tas de sujets avec des
magistrats et
on a commencé à sentir quand même que
sur la question du procès il fallait
être sûr que
un dialogue sous
[Musique]
nous au parquet général on se met en
ordre de marche qui d'abord une
réflexion dans quelle structure peut-on
accueillir un tel procès
[Musique]
une des hypothèses pouvaient être
d'externaliser le procès parce que 1700
partie civile trois cent cinquante
avocats ça on n'a jamais vu
la première commande de la chancellerie
elle vous avez dépassé en novembre 2018
il s'agissait de trouver sur paris ou en
ile de france ou bien lieu sur lequel on
serait en capacité donc de construire
une salle de cette capacité de 2500
personnes puisque c'était donc
l'effectif de référence qui nous avait
été donné pour nos recherches ou bien de
trouver un lieu existant qui sera
susceptible d'être réaménagé d'être
adapté pour accueillir ce procès on
évacue une salle de spectacle pour les
raisons que vous imaginez bien puisque
c'est le bataclan qu'on juge notamment
et on va pas aller s'installer au palais
des congrès pour pour juger ce tu as
fais donc pas de salle de spectacle
personnellement moi j'ai la conviction
que en dépit des difficultés et de la
dimension il serait préférable d'avoir
un lieu de justice
[Musique]
avril 2019 la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet a confirmé le choix du palais
de justice historique de l'île de la
cité
ce palais
construit par nos ancêtres à qui est a
pas de justice depuis onze siècles
présente des atouts vous avez des murs
qui font que ce pas de justice sans être
tout à fait un bunker présente des
atouts en termes de sécurité
[Musique]
et tenir ce procès auprès du site de
paris au coeur de paris là où les
attentats ont eu lieu eh bien ça sera un
beau symbole de résistance de la
démocratie de l'état de droit que le
terrorisme n'aura pas atteint
on est confronté à la nécessité de
construire une grande salle d'audience
mais qui ne soit pas pour autant un hall
de gare à l'entrepôt un espace immense
où finalement quand on entre dans la
salle on voit tout au fond des
personnages en tous petits dont on vous
dira que c'est la cour d'assises la
jauge a été fixé à peu près à 550
personnes et pour être en capacité
d'accueillir le plus grand nombre nous
allons mobiliser et salle d'audience
supplémentaire au sein de la cour
d'appel pour permettre aux uns et aux
autres de pouvoir suivre par un système
de vidéotransmission les débats
non
moi je suis allé au can je suis un des
chefs de projet en charge de la
construction de la salle d'audience
provisoire qui s'implantera dans le
volume ici de la salle des pas perdus
donc aujourd'hui on a une entreprise
monuments historiques spécialisée dans
le travail de la pierre qui vient des
chaussées au pied des piles la partie de
dalle sur laquelle on va pouvoir ensuite
en dessous faire reposer l'assemblée
danse provisions liées
aujourd'hui on est en national une
activité très calme avec une première
intervention très maîtrisée dans les
prochaines semaines il faudra beaucoup
d'entreprises travaillent en même temps
pour réussir à construire cette salle
d'audience comme on l'a imaginé avec
avec l'architecte dans tous les bureaux
d'études travaillent beaucoup plus
animée
[Musique]
ça en fait c'est tout c'est tout ce
qu'on a regroupé de
d'éléments alors deux des avocats
deux des assos des renseignements qu'on
recherche
des bouquins
la presse aussi que la forêt si je
voulais voir la presse et les truies
sont sorties no calepin mon calepin de
notes
à chaque fois qu'on va quelque part on
note et puis après on
rassemble tout ça dans la mallette s'est
arrangé tu vois
avocat voilà les différents documents
qu'on a besoin a présenté en tant que
partie civile etc le reste c'est bas
toutes les informations qu'on garde
aussi j'ai fait tout ça à la base le but
premier c'est de défendre ses droits
il peut pas le faire il peut plus le
faire c'était défendre ses droits on se
portant partie civile en prenant un
avocat c'était poursuivre
pour suivre le plus prêt à voir les
enfants quoi si sa pochette qui est
préparé
je pense qu'il faudra ya déjà des
papiers à rangée de dents mais elle est
préparée sa pochette c'est une
succession de deux grosses journées de
petites journées une succession de
moments on se dira peut-être
as-tu à vue là il a il a parlé ou pas
parler peu importe mais il s'est passé
ça et ce rsa
mais je ne pense pas que qu'on arrive à
quelque chose de vraiment de révélateur
et si on en fait pas justement le procès
du siècle
parce qu'on aimerait avoir le procès du
siècle
[Musique]
pour un avocat avant une place dans ce
procès c'est un événement dans une
carrière c'est peut-être même
l'événement dans notre carrière c'est
une grande responsabilité vis-à-vis des
victimes c'est aussi pour nous un rendez
vous dans notre palais de justice comme
nous n'en connaîtrons et je l'espère
jamais ultérieurement il y a une
motivation
folle aussi à participer à ce procès de
la façon la plus complète soit elle
bonjour pagnol beaucoup at il
lancé
alors
bon on va faire un petit point sur le
procès à venir donc j'ai reçu comme vous
êtes domicilié à mon cabinet j'ai reçu
une convocation pour le procès devant la
cour d'assises donc je vous remets à
chacune votre votre exemplaire alors la
convocation de la garder avec vous
accompagné des victimes d'attentats
s'est pas seulement faire de la
procédure c'est pas faire seulement du
droit de la réparation c'est un échange
et humain exceptionnel est fabuleux on
accompagne les gens dans leur
désespérance dans leurs espoirs dans
leurs émotions on les voit pleurer on
rit parfois avec elle on a comme une
relation unique qui
dépasse le cadre
classique avocat clients on vit des
choses extrêmement forte avec les gens
la toiture tu peux tu vas travailler sur
leurs tubes les denrées sur qui alors
moi je vais pas
c'est une vraie question qu'est ce que
je vais plaider c'est un vrai sujet être
avocat de partie civile je pense qu'il
faut pas se tromper c'est pas c'est pas
porter l'accusation c'est vous
accompagner c'est c'est peut-être
présente à chaque fois que vous viendrez
à l'audience pour vous expliquer la
façon dont ça se passe c'est que chaque
victime
est la possibilité de participer à son
procès de le comprendre voilà en fait le
contenu de la plaidoirie on veut on
travaillera ensemble au fur et à mesure
[Musique]
quand j'ai rencontré les gens qui
allaient devenir mes clients
dans la minute où je leur ai dit oui et
pour moi la question ne s'est pas posé
leur dire non j'ai entrevu la montagne
que sa lettre donc la question a été de
savoir comment on allait faire
c'était une évidence qu'on pouvait pas
aborder ce dossier
seul ce qu'on a fait et qui nous a
qui nous a soudés c'était le procès des
logeurs des terroristes du 13 novembre
jawad bendaoud youssef et où la scène
notamment et on a essayé en fait au fil
des questions et après de l'audience et
ensuite des plaidoiries de s'organiser
pour faire une trame commune de
plaidoirie répartis entre plusieurs
avocats pour qu'on y est il n'y a pas de
répétition pour faire gagner aussi du
temps
au tribunal est ce qu'on pourra à la
reproduire
à l'échelle du procès du 13 novembre
c'est c'est toute la question parce que
évidemment il ya beaucoup plus d'avocat
il ya beaucoup plus de plaidoiries
à faire et beaucoup plus d'enjeu pour
tout le monde alors ce que nous avons
fait avec un certain nombre d'avocats
c'est que nous sommes regroupés au sein
du barreau un groupement pénale a été
organisée
la coordination via ce groupe pénale est
absolument indispensable en vue du
procès du lieu des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 indispensable pour tout
vous dire on ne sait pas encore
exactement comment ça va se passer pour
nous aussi c'est totalement inédit
pour nos avocats parfois c'est difficile
de s'entendre à quatre survivants a donc
à 80 c'était pas évident à 300 c'est
encore plus compliqué
alors je n'en doute pas mais c'est bien
d'avoir quand même des garde-fous quoi
on l'a vu c'est compliqué c'est un c'est
un vrai sujet
et moi je fais partie des personnes sont
convaincues que la dignité du procès
repose sur l'autodiscipline oui mais ce
n'est pas déjà fait puis tu vas un
process à valigloo retard tu fais face à
les accuser c'est en plus t'es pas aidé
par les avocats il faut pas que les gens
pepy et cac est dans n'importe quel sens
et donc il est indispensable que nous
nous organisions mais c est une raison
qui est importante c'est la dignité
qu'on doit aux gens qui sont morts c'est
la dignité qu'on joue qu'on doit aux
gens qui ont été blessés ou qui ont été
traumatisés et à leurs familles si nous
le jour du procès nous ne sommes pas
capables d'être digne que veut nous nous
faire dans une enceinte comme celle ci
cette salle devait être construite puis
ensuite être en capacité d'être démonté
sans qu'il n'y ait aucune trace visible
dans la salle des poches
qu'avec les interruptions liées à la
crise sanitaire que le chantier a
réellement démarré à la fin du mois de
mai 2020 depuis nous avons réalisé les
ancrages
poser construit l'ensemble de la
charpente métallique qui représente
vraiment l'ossature en fait qui retient
l'ensemble de la salle
vous êtes c'est à l'emplacement de la
future table de justice au
positionnement du quasiment à la place
du futur président d'audience vous
regardez vers le prétoire d'abord les
avocats des parties civiles et de la
défense le box des accusés qui sera
positionnée ici et derrière l'auditoire
il se prolonge sur toute la longueur de
la salle d'audience
[Musique]
c'est un procès qui va se dérouler
devant une cour d'assises spécialement
constituée c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
comme tous les procès terroristes aux
assises
ça veut dire que ce ne sont pas des
jurés populaires comme on a l'habitude
dans des affaires de meurtres de viols
de trafic de stupéfiants par exemple
[Musique]
c'est un choix qui est qui remonte
maintenant à plusieurs années qui a été
fait pour la protection des citoyens on
estime qu'il peut y avoir des menaces
sur les citoyens qu'on est dans une
matière qui est particulièrement
dangereuse pas qui soulève des questions
de sécurité plus importante et donc on a
voulu les protéger on met des magistrats
professionnels
[Musique]
le président il a il va avoir un rôle
crucial ça peut changer du tout au tout
une odieux déroulé d'une audience on va
avoir des présidents qui seront très
dynamique doit pas du tout des
présidents qui vont laisser qui savent
amené la parole la confession et
d'autres beaucoup moins des présidents
qui vont laisser une place à l'imprévu
que peut constituer un procès aux
assises et d'autres qui vont se tenir à
tout prix à leur planning voilà il ya
vraiment des caractères différents et ça
donne des procès qui sont très
différents
[Musique]
je m'appelle régis de jorna je suis
président de la cour d'assises à paris
un des présidents de cours d'assises à
paris en matière de terrorisme j'ai
présidé des procès en matière de
terrorisme corse le procès carlos et le
procès également des attentats de
janvier 2015 le président a une
responsabilité c'est lui qui dirige le
procès et en matière de cours d'assises
rien n'est écrit à l'avancé
[Musique]
je ne connais pas de procès aussi lourd
a présidé en raison de la charge émotive
qu'il y aura lors des débats à voir
l'évocation
de 130 vie fracassée ce sera extrêmement
lourd extrêmement dur
un procès à une ambiance
on le sent c'est palpable il peut y
avoir des moments
gérer de grandes tensions ya aussi des
moments de sérénité
des moments plus calmes
c'est le président de faire attention et
ça se sent
donc le président
qui est à la table de justice
en son centre entouré des assesseurs et
et puis
sur la droite
l'avocat général qui représente la
société qui va soutenir l'accusation
les avocats généraux ils s'expliqueront
devant la cour quels sont à leurs yeux
les éléments qui doivent être tenus pour
déterminer s'il estime la culpabilité de
chacun des accusés deux des trois
magistrats du parquet antiterroriste qui
sont pressentis pour porter l'accusation
dans cette affaire devant la cour
d'assises était lors de la nuit des
faits sur les lieux sur place il ya donc
une véritable continuité que le parquet
antiterroriste a pu mettre en place et
c'est quelque chose tout affaibli
philippe de faits nouveaux
[Musique]
il
à
je viens ici pour faire une visite de
chantier et constater l'évolution des
travaux
vous êtes ici au sein de la salle des
pas perdus du palais de justice
historique de paris et ses 45 mètres de
long
15 mètres de large donc pour une
superficie totale d'un peu moins de 700
mhz étage je vous propose d'avancer au
niveau du prétoire
vous l'avez le boxe boxe le box donc
parfaitement sécurisée vaut en terme de
capacité bon c'est un box
d'une taille jamais j'en ai réalisé
jusque là alors le le box est
complètement refermé le complètement
couvert alors il est fermé par en fait
une pergola en bois c'est à dire qu'elle
ça va permettre la circulation de l'air
en revanche ce ne sera pas franchissable
on aura dans le box soit des auteurs
directs soit des auteurs très proche des
auteurs directs en dehors de sanaa
abdeslam tous ceux qui ont participé à
la préparation à la logistique à
l'organisation
porte une responsabilité pénale très
forte on est en train de nous préparer
au procès c'est à dire qu'on est en
train de nous préparer psychologiquement
pour comprendre qu'un procès aux assises
c'est plutôt
définir la responsabilité de chaque
individu qui est dans le box
voilà c'est clair c'est à dire que à la
limite vous les parties civiles
c'est parce c'est pas vous c'est pas
votre procès c'est leur procès
[Musique]
alors les accusés qui vont comparaître
dans le box lors du procès des attentats
du 13 novembre ils vont être 14 et on
peut les séparer en plusieurs groupes le
premier groupe ce sont les six membres
présumés du commando salle abdeslam qui
est le seul survivant des commandos de
paris qui est considéré comme un des
principaux accusés mais attention il
n'est pas seul il ya d'autres personnes
très importantes il ya aussi mohamed
abri mis qui je le rappelle était venu à
paris juste avant les attentats et on
est parti juste avant la commission et
qui est également celui qu'on appelait
l'homme au chapeau à bruxelles des
attentats de bruxelles à leurs côtés il
ya un tunisien sofiane ayari et un
suédois osamac ryan dungey a dit ce
qu'elle est et aguerris en syrie qui
sont suspectés d'avoir fait des
repérages
à les reports ski paul d'amsterdam le 13
novembre et d'avoir aussi contribué aux
préparatifs des attentats s'y ajoutent
le pakistanais mohammed osman et
l'algérien adel haddadi ce sont deux
djihadistes qui ont été arrêtés dans un
centre pour migrants en autriche et on
estime qu'ils devaient peut-être
constituer un commando supplémentaires
un autre groupe sont les amis de salles
abdeslam qui va contacter une fois qu'il
était à châtillon dans le sud de paris
pour l'aider à revenir à bruxelles donc
il ya mohamed amri hamza à tous et
alioui qui habille les deux derniers
vont comparaître libre parce qu'ils ont
été placés sous contrôle judiciaire
l'autre groupe se est constituée de cinq
logisticiens présumés on va citer
mohamed bakkali qui est suspecté d'avoir
loué des voitures et des appartements il
ya également ali el adha soufi ya
abdellah choix qui comparaît lui libre
et sous contrôle judiciaire il ya yacine
haddar quelques uns des jeunes frères de
oussama atar qui est soupçonné d'avoir
été présent lors de certains préparatifs
et en plus le présumé fournisseur de
faux papiers qui est farine car cache un
autre suspect va être jugé en son
absence donc c'est ahmed hamani amène
dahmani a fui depuis la belgique juste
après la commission des attentats dans
les heures qui ont suivi il a été arrêté
alors qu'il essayait de rejoindre à
cyril a été arrêté en turquie il est
actuellement en prison là dont bien sûr
tous ces prévenus ils sont présumés
innocents avant d'avoir été jugé et de
manière définitive et leurs rôles
respectifs leurs responsabilités c'est
ça dont on va débattre pendant ce procès
et enfin dans le procès il ya des
accusés qu'on peut appeler les accusés
fantôme qui ne seront pas présents sont
des personnes qui sont présumées
décédées en syrie lors de bombardements
ou deux frappes de drones comme la
preuve de leur mort n'a pas pu être
fournis ils seront quand même jugé
l'action ne s'éteint pas à leur mort
parce qu'on n'a pas la preuve de leur
mort et l'enquète a établi leurs liens
avec la cdu du 13 et donc ces présumés
morts donc il ya bien évidemment oussama
atar qui est considéré comme le cerveau
des attentats qui a été tuées en syrie
fin 2017 il ya un artificier syriens
dont on n'a retrouvé l'adn sur les
ceintures explosives des attentats qui
s'appelle omar darif il ya également le
responsable de la formation des
commandos ans si rien celui qu'a et d
ollars recrutement les informer et à
aider au transfert il s'appelle obeïd
adibou et évidemment les derniers qui
sont les frères toulousains bien connu
jean michel et fabien klein dont les
voix ont été formellement identifiés
comme ayant enregistré le message de
revendication qui a fait suite aux
attentats du 13 novembre
et qui ont également été tués dans des
frappes dans des frappes sur en syrie
[Musique]
donc ce que risquent ces prévenus bain
certains vont risquer la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour complicité
de crimes terroristes qui est le chef
d'accusation des chefs d'accusations
plus graves pour la plupart des accusés
d autres accusés ils sont renvoyés
principalement pour une participation
présumée aux préparatifs et donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle la mt ou l'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes il encourt
jusqu'à 20 ans de prison
[Musique]
ce procès historique des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 va nous permettre de
comprendre dans une dimension inédite ce
qu'on va appeler la politique pénale et
en particulier de cette incrimination si
particulière de l'association de
malfaiteurs terroristes à savoir définir
qui appartient au groupe
ayant participé à l'acte terroriste
est-ce que la complicité se fait rare
l'action matériel de fourniture des
armes de participation à l'attaqué
est-ce que la participation à
l'association de malfaiteurs terroristes
se fait aussi à travers
l'intentionnalité et jusqu où va cet
intentionnalité à savoir la connaissance
du but terroriste de l'association de
malfaiteurs nous défendons l'égalité -
monsieur amri
qui est poursuivi pour
être venu chercher sa lave les flammes
le soin d attente admise attentat et
d'avoir ramené en belgique
à qui on ne reproche pas la complicité
par aide ou assistance à sale abdeslam
donc on considère qu'il ne savait pas ce
qui allait se passer en aidant abdeslam
à aller louer des véhicules pourtant on
lui reproche l'association des futurs
terroristes
alors qu'est ce qu'on exige que cette
personne aurait dû savoir et ces points
vont devenir des points essentiels pour
les stratégies de la défense afin de
montrer en quoi
l'expérience de la justice
antiterroriste depuis 2015 s'inscrit
dans une politique pénale toujours plus
sévères toujours plus large envers la mt
et qui
officiellement et de manière totalement
transparente
affirme une nouvelle échelle des peines
avec des condamnations toujours plus
lourdes
[Musique]
il faut d'ailleurs sortir de ce fantasme
selon lequel il y aurait un laxisme qui
pourraient exister en matière terroriste
s'il ya bien un domaine du droit où ça
n'existe pas et on a pu constater dans
chacun de nos dossiers c'est bien en
matière d'association de malfaiteurs
terroristes
[Musique]
comment expliquer notre notre métier à
l'opinion publique surtout quand on
défend ce qu'on appelle l'indéfendable
les difficultés on les rencontre dans
nos cellules familiales
dans le cercle d'amis
parfois même chez nous comme chez des
confrères
la meilleure réponse en réalité à se
lasser c'est de répondre qu'on est là
pour faire du droit on ne défend pas
l'acte mais on défend la personne qui a
commis l'acte et que vous soyez
terroristes vous vous soyez pédophile ou
meurtrier d'enfants vous avez les mêmes
droits et des droits c'est le procès
équitable c'est l'accès à l'avocat
[Musique]
tout le monde dans la préparation de ce
procès il est bien que tous les accusés
et que tous les intervenants puissent
préparer ce procès au mieux
ça va être une journée c'est toute une
aventure où va à lyon d'abord et puis
ensuite on prend le thé vert pour
villefranche sur saône pour marcher
ensuite jusqu'à la maison d'arrêt où
nous avons parloir à 14h avec notre
client monsieur haddad dit tout à
l'heure
il a isolement total
il faut à personne à part nous est sa
seule angoisse au quotidien c'est le
procès qui arrive donc il est quand même
légitime et normal en tout cas c'est le
un aspect essentiel de notre rôle
d'aller le voir et lui expliquer où on
en est comment ça va se passer et de
commencer à préparer sa défense
[Musique]
je pense qu'on prête aux avocats souvent
un pouvoir qu'ils n'ont pas en fait
l'idée serait de construire
artificiellement des réponses une
défense et en fait ça se passe pas du
tout c'est pas du tout comme ça n'arrive
pas avec une liste de questions en
l'usant apprendre par coeur les réponses
qu'on espère qui donnera le jour venu en
fait on le conseille dans un premier
temps la lidc est-ce que vous
reconnaissez les faits qu'on vous
reproche ou non partir du moment où il
les reconnaît en l'occurrence c'est le
cas la majeure partie des faits qui lui
sont reprochés
l'idée c'est de lui laisser la parole
pour s'expliquer pour s'exprimer en fait
ce n'est pas à moi de raconter à sa
place son histoire ou de la transformer
pour qu'elle me convient le mieux
[Musique]
pour un avocat de la défense
je pense que cet exercice ultime des
droits de la défense que d'assister en
accusé dans un procès de cette envergure
c'est un procès y avoir un enjeu
cathartique énorme pour les victimes
pour la population
mais où pour autant il faut pas basculer
dans une justice qui devient une
vengeance
il faut s'assurer que les droits de la
défense sont respectées
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est
évidemment extrêmement important de
participer à ce procès est d'être aux
côtés de l'accusé
je pense que c'était bien utile et que
c'était le bon moment ce qui nous avait
attendu quand même pendant l'été
septembre a été long aussi je pense que
c'est bien parce qu'on a pu passer
vraiment du temps avec lui presse aime
bien on est resté une heure et demie 1
et on a pu commencer à lui expliquer
comment se passe le le cour d'assises
mais qu'il est visuellement qu'il est
visuellement une assez on a pu lui
disney la salle d'audience de chacun
j'avais expliqué qu'il aurait des
questions à la fois de l'avocat général
la fois des parties civiles à la fois de
nous ce qui est intéressant à ce qui est
bien ce qu'on a fait là et c'est un
exercice qu'on fait avec lui depuis
depuis qu'on va le voir c'est de
l'amener à réfléchir et à commencer à
avoir des bribes de
de réponse sur quel était son état
d'esprit qu'est-ce-qu'il l'amener ici
est-ce qu'il a pris du recul par rapport
aux faits qui lui sont reprochés et même
suffisamment de recul par rapport à
lui-même
pour apporter des explications
plus dense
devant la cour mais c'est un exercice
compliqué pour lui et qui a fortiori du
coup est compliqué pour nous le chemin
est encore long
où
[Musique]
m
avant même le stade des peines qui
pourrait être prononcé
vous êtes vous avez une certaine
curiosité d'entendre ce qu'ils ont à
dire parce qu'ils ont a dit miller moi
ça je pense que c'est bien un des items
auquel je n'irai pas oui aucun aucun des
noms là franchement non je pense que les
actes valent parole
oui après les pour apporter la
contradiction et te pousser un peu dans
ses retranchements jeu de te diraient
ils sont ils comparaissent présumé
innocent c'est à dire oui on le moment
ils ne sont pas déclarés coupables et
ccdh a quand même un grand principe du
droit c'est pour le moment il ya eu une
enquête et pour certains d'entre eux
alors pour certains c'est la voilà la
culpabilité est évidente pour d'autres
c'est plus compliqué c'est plus subtil
c'est ils sont pas tous impliqués de la
safer est ce que ça vous sait quelque
chose même sur le plan intellectuel que
vous attendez de de pouvoir éclaircir
c'est à dire de savoir qu'elle est quel
est le rôle de chacun qui a eu peur
après le but de ce procès c'est aussi de
tu vois c'est le procédé des clous et
nous c'est de savoir c'est il ya quand
même une qui ait fait attendre de
deux vérités sur qui va être quoi
comment
c'est pas parce que on a envie de savoir
qui a fait quoi comment le contexte
qu'on a envie de les entendre eux
l'actualité en france c'est aussi ce
procès qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui devant
une cour d'assises spéciale à paris
celui de l'auteur présumé de l'attentât
de villejuif tête en 2015 sid ahmed glam
récuser d'avoir tué il ya quatre ans on
se souvient avec juifs aurélie chacune
un professeur de fitness croisé par
hasard sur le parking où il préparait
visiblement son assaut contre une église
j'avais envie de venir aujourd'hui parce
que sarhane ça nous met un petit peu
dans le bain de ce qu'on va vivre dans
une petite année on imagine mais je
pense que on est loin de ce qu'on va de
ses combats subir
et
et je pense que si on car tout petit peu
préparée et bien c'est toujours savent
gagner c'est toujours sable qui sera
peut-être un peu moins difficile ces
montants là de surmonter l'idée c'est
que la corée 6 personne ne sait ce que
c'est avant d'y être allé donc on a un
procès qui est beaucoup plus petit qui à
taille humaine vous une humaine mais
jean qui rit il n'y a pas de milliers de
victimes ce qui permet finalement de
bien en temps de participer de se rendre
compte de ce qui se passe de voir aussi
ce que c'est que quelqu'un qui m'ont
c'est sûr que on en aurait envie d'avoir
toutes les réponses quand bien compte
que là c'est ils mentent tout voilà ça
ressemble à rien des gens n'ont pas ce
qu'ils attendent c'est sûr
un procédé au restée très souvent
décevants de par le comportement
des acteurs c'est-à-dire des accusés ça
c'est une constante quelle que soit la
forme de terrorisme on ne connaît pas
deux procès notamment devant la cour
d'assises en matière de terrorisme au
cours desquelles nous aurons bien qu'usé
qui sont médias bien voilà j'ai fait
cela pour tel et tel motif et j'explique
cela de manière claire compréhensible et
je n'apprécie pas acceptable si on peut
employer ce terme effroyable pour les
victimes ta moi personnellement toi
aussi je pense je n'attends pas des
révélations
extraordinaires ouais ouais ouais
salam salam venant me dire pardon
excusez moi non non j'attends pas ça
j'attends d'avoir quand même avec les
différentes interventions qui lui aura
les
d'avoir un éclairage sur le sur tout ce
qui s'est passé mais dans un ensemble
soyons très clairs si la personne ne
parle pas et que tout le monde se traîne
à ses genoux pour qu'elle parle on se
remettra en position de victime une
deuxième fois en face de quelqu'un qui
retrouvera son ascendant sur des
victimes alors remettre en place est à
100 dons c'est mortifère et c'est
inutile ya une règle moi que je me suis
toujours fixé
c'est de ne jamais être suspendue aux
lèvres
la criminelle serait t'il terroriste
donc l'important ce sera de poser des
questions pour les réponses nous verrons
tout ce qu'ils pourront dire ne pourra
pas être plus violent que ce qu'ils ont
fait
donc ils pourront dire ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est fait et c'est ça qui est qui
reste en fait après les paroles
oui ça peut être ça peut être choquant
ça peut être blessant ça peut être
humiliant ça peut être violent mais est
ce qu'est ce qui est plus violent que ce
qu'ils ont fait
au procès de glam mois ce qui masque
image fait drouot fin choqué et a porté
c'est qu'il y avait les parents de la
jeune fille et de voir leur émotion de
voir leur
comment il était
je me suis pas projeté dedans mais
c'était pas loin quoi et je me suis dit
on va on va être dans cet état là on va
vivre ce que ces gens là sont en train
de vivre et du coup je pense que ça ça
nous
ça nous a permis ça va nous permettre de
du coup d'appréhender - certaines choses
[Musique]
alors
on est parties civiles on reçoit on soit
d des cd rom
on a d ordonnance de mise en accusation
on a les notifications d'arrêts des
conclusions des expertises et voilà tous
ces documents là ça nous permet de
trouver des informations on a commencé
par le bataclan le stade de france et
les terrasses
et après on a ce qu'on va rencontrer va
avoir et qu'il va falloir qu'on
comprenne aussi
leur chemin on a refait une fiche pour
chaque personne qu'on trouve dedans
et en fait dès qu'on va trouver un
renseignement
x ou y dans le réquisitoire au lieu de
prendre des notes à la suite et en
finalité s'embrouiller ben on va
directement sur la fiche de la personne
en le note on s'est mis d'accord sur une
façon de faire une espèce de petite
carte d'identité de ces gens là ça va
nous permettre de de les assimiler pour
que le jour du procès on puisse mieux le
vivre
et sans être perturbé par ses émotions
et essayer de l'adama siam maximum
d'informations sans perdre de temps à se
rappeler qui est qui
[Musique]
on est peut-être impressionné par la
longueur de la salle il faut rappeler
que à intervalles réguliers il y aura
des écrans pour que les personnes qui
prendront place au milieu et au son de
la salle puisse visionner des acteurs du
procès et lui un vrai travail sur la
conception acoustique de la salle qui a
été menée justement pour permettre cette
bonne compréhension des débats
aujourd'hui nous travaillons à
l'implantation des mobiliers en fait on
a certains dans qui sont en fait des
bancs extensible à qui vont pouvoir
s'est retirée pour permettre
éventuellement des clients davantage de
personnes ça c'est très astucieux
c'est très bien j'ai travaillé même sur
la hauteur de la table a confiance en
que ce soit le plus confortable pour le
plus ergonomique et nous avons pris en
témoin le plus grand des magistrats très
bien
[Musique]
c'est confortable
ça avec une très belle réalisation
c'est impressionnant
merci beaucoup pour cette visite on voit
que le chantier évolue très bien que le
calendrier suivi nous sommes très
rassuré de voir que cette très belle
salle d'audience
s'édifie tout en respectant et ça c'est
important
l' architecture historique du psg c'est
pour nous
extrêmement réconfort merci beaucoup
[Musique]
juste un petit vérification est ce que
tout le monde entend bien si vous qu'on
veut mettre des petits pouces
ouais aurélie dit que ça on entend bien
super alors
vous aurez compris que notre objectif
c'est d'essayer d'arriver à ce procès
non pas de façon individuelle mais en
étant le plus organisé possible pour
proposer une défense des parties civiles
qui soit à la fois résonné à la fois
digne efficaces ont réfléchi à ça depuis
longtemps et on aura besoin de toutes
les bonnes volontés pour le faire on a
la chance d'avoir avec nous jean
reinhart est clair josserand schmidt qui
sont aussi sur le procès des attentats
de janvier
c'est tout à fait en fait passionnant de
s'apercevoir en quoi malheureusement
j'allais dire parfois le procès dit de
charlie hebdo est hyper cacher sont un
peu le numéro 0 de notre procès du 13
novembre est ce qu'on aura des tablettes
est ce qu'on aura des micros à notre
table dans charge dans le procès de
janvier 2015 on avait quelques bancs
dans la salle principale très peu
étaient
affublés d'une tablette donc nous avons
quasiment tous des problèmes de
cervicales a travaillé pendant trois
mois avec mon ordinateur sur les genoux
ce sont des petites choses auxquelles on
ne pense pas nécessairement en amont
mais qui sont importants ça va
constituer nos conditions de travail
pendant six sept huit neuf mois en
france est pas exactement l'évidence si
on commence au mois de septembre
c'est une grande fatigue nerveuse une
grande fatigue physique une grande
fatigue tout court et qu'en conséquence
salvat explose en plein vol ce qui veut
dire que moi tels que je vois les choses
par exemple mais il faut qu'on en
débatte tous ensemble je crois fermement
que il faut allonger le calendrier on
part dans un marathon et je je pense que
il faut travailler chacun des points de
façon très patiente la salle leçon la
retransmission les questions qui sont
posées
les les travaux qui doivent être
réalisés par tous
tous les acteurs
du monde judiciaire on va dire au sens
large scrute ce procès là
parce qu'évidemment qu'il a une sorte
d'idée de répétition générale de ce que
peut donner le procès du 13 novembre à
la différence près que c'est la petite
répétition générale et qu'en termes de
proportion va à peu près multiplié par
dix
quelques idées pour un président
d'association comme moi et d'ailleurs
pour une partie civile c'est de venir
voir un peu comment ça se passe de
comprendre quatre sont les enjeux qui
aller quelque part la dramaturgie
quelles sont les choses extrêmement
difficile qu'on n'arrive pas à prévoir
manière théorique mais qu'on voit de
façon pratique
charlotte pyrèthre en direct du palais
de justice de paris il y à des
événements qui nous parque tout sa vie
il ya des procès plus que d'autres qui
font trembler la voix ce doux et la
gorge et les entrailles il y à des
parcours qui font écraser des larmes
discrètement derrière son masque trois
mois après le début de cette audience
qui nous a tous je pense saisit ici au
procès des attentats de janvier ça a été
la diffusion des images de la rédaction
de charlie hebdo dans la foulée de
l'attentât c'est des images qui sont qui
était au dossier mais qu'on n'avait pas
forcément vraiment vu et en tout cas pas
dans le cas d'une cour d'assises sur
grand écran pendant le longues minutes
c'est des images qui s'imprime sur la
rétine et qui forcément nous touchons un
citoyen êtres humains etc la
manifestation de la vérité impose que
soit évoqué des scènes parfois très durs
très très dur peut-être même choquant
pas pour le plaisir de montrer pas pour
le plaisir de faire du sensationnel mais
parce que c'est la vérité et la
manifestation de la vérité c'est dire
voir entendre pour que chacun puisse
savoir ce qui s'est réellement passé
[Musique]
quand je viens là même si c'est pas mon
affaire même si c'est pas les accusés
que moi j'aurais en face je n'arrive pas
du tout à m'en détacher
et d'ailleurs c'est ça que je trouve
effrayant c'est que j'arrive pas
anticipé ce que je vais vraiment vivre
quand ce sera mon procès à moi je sens
déjà que l'intensité que que je ressens
la j'arriverai pas la vivre en venant
cinq jours par semaine
m
c'est long c'est évidemment lourd c'est
une charge émotionnelle importante
oui oui c'est un véritable marathon on
s'y attendait et malgré tout quand on
est dedans on accuse toujours un peu
coup
[Musique]
pour on parle quand même du vin qui
vient de se mettre à nu raconter leurs
souffrances
pour certains se défendre vis-à-vis
d'une peine s'il peut être énorme et
donc à la fin tous enlève quand les gens
parlent de tous enlève quand les avocats
parlent quand le président parle et tout
ce qui reste c'est de l'humain on peut
parler de justice mme parler de plein de
choses et à la fin tout ce qui reste des
sommes qu'ils jugent dos d'homme et on
s'en rend compte quand on vient d'un
procès comme ça
[Musique]
plus j'avance dans ce procès s'il est
moins j'arrive à imaginer ce que va être
celui du 13 novembre ont en tout cas
plus je vois les difficultés qui vont
être soulevée pour ce procès là en terme
de lourdeur de durée d'audience de
nombre de victimes et de personnes de
témoins à entendre de nombre d'accusés
enfin tout va être dans des proportions
encore plus grandes et déjà ici c'est
loin d'être simple que de tenir ce
procès là et cette audience
[Musique]